a quiet Sunday Min for worship turns
into commotion a bomb rips through a
Catholic gathering in the southern
Philippine city of marawi killing
several people and injuring dozens
more the explosion was so strong it felt
like lightning
struck hasmin suffered a deep cut on her
toe and her husband nearly lost his
eyesight but they Greatful their alive
31-year-old Evangeline aromin wasn't as
lucky her brother
and best friend Le learned about her and
saw her body on social
media when I first saw the picture I
cried and said in front of my wife
Evangeline where are you why did you
leave
us Akino says he's accepted Evangeline's
fate but senior security officials here
have promised to bring the perpetrators
to Justice they say they've launched an
operation to search for Persons of
Interest but won't divulge much else
isil has claimed responsibility for the
bombing of the gymnasium in marawi city
now president Fran Marcus Jr blames what
he calls foreign terrorists but security
officials say they're still looking into
all possible
angles they've zeroed in on fighters who
they think may be retaliating against
recent offensives that resulted in the
killing of their leaders and have
suspected ties with ISO we cannot really
uh say for sure whether uh these are
foreigners coming to the Philippines and
uh doing the that attack or whether
these are affiliated groups to uh
foreign terrorist groups no or even
foreign
directed the government has deployed
additional troops to marawi and the rest
of the southern region but has assured
the public that there is no imminent
threat bar below Al jazer City Southern
Philippines make sure to subscribe to
our channel to get the latest news from
Al
jazer